clashes between police and protesters in
Ecuador's capital city evil show no sign
of relenting police used flashbang
grenades and tear gas to disperse the
crowds demonstrators say authorities
have also used live ammunition against
peaceful protesters the ongoing protests
have paralyzed much of downtown Quito
amidst the chaos and clouds of tear gas
medical patients could be seen fleeing
nearby hospitals we couldn't have
imagined this situation it's horrifying
to see our people fighting one another
after more than a week of unrest
indigenous demonstrators continue to
arrive from across the country to
participate in the ongoing
anti-government demonstrations some
traveling from communities as far away
as the Amazon to join the frontlines
we've come from far away leaving our
families behind now we're here to
participate in the National strike so
the government could show us some
respect in a pre-recorded message to the
nation on Friday Ecuador's president
Lanie Morano asked for a direct dialogue
with leaders within the National
Confederation of indigenous communities
this indispensable it's imperative that
we end the violence we need solutions to
the issues of our country I'm calling on
leaders to speak with me directly
outside Ecuador's National Assembly
Building demonstrators were once again
met with sound grenades and tear gas
several demonstrators as well as police
officers were injured during the
confrontation
despite the Ecuadorian president's call
for a national dialogue tensions still
remain very high here in Quito
demonstrators say that they're angry
over the heavy-handed response by
authorities against peaceful protesters
if anything these clashes between
demonstrators and police only appear to
be intensifying indigenous leaders have
agreed to sit down for talks with the
president but with growing calls for the
authorities to bring back order to the
streets there's concern the violence
could get even worse when rapido
azita keep doing weather